en medio de una jornada negra en las
bolsas europeas los líderes de los 27
han querido enviar un mensaje de calma y
de tranquilidad de hecho el canciller
Alemán ola ha querido calmar las aguas
entre la situación de doitchebank que ha
registrado enormes caídas desde que
empezó la jornada en que ha mostrado su
confianza a total al banco y que no hay
motivos para los que preocuparse los 27
líderes de la Unión Europea se han
reunido en Bruselas para abordar la
situación económica o un punto que ya
está previsto de antes en la agenda en
quien ha escuchado la presidenta del
Banco Central europeo Christine lagart a
hablar de las medidas que se han tomado
hasta ahora para atajar la altísima
inflación en la eurozona Como por
ejemplo la subida de tipos de medio
punto anunciada la semana pasada pero
también el claro de mensaje de que se
inyectará liquidez a los bancos si hace
falta en cualquier caso Christine lagar
también ha pedido a los gobiernos que
tomen las medidas necesarias Como por
ejemplo cerrar la reforma bancaria
pendiente desde la crisis de 2008 los
líderes europeos han admitido que es una
cuestión pendiente pero que tienen total
confianza en el sistema financiero en
cualquier caso la comisión europea ha
anunciado nuevas medidas en los próximos
días para hacer frente a futuras crisis
aunque los líderes europeos han
insistido el sistema bancario es fuerte
y se están tomando todas las medidas
necesarias por lo que es necesario
calmar cuanto antes los mercados